this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer last month
Tesla held an event for their investors
revealing the advances they had made in
their autonomous driving capabilities
currently most Tesla vehicles are
capable of enhancing the drivers
abilities it can take over the tedious
task of maintaining lanes and highways
monitor and match the speeds of
surrounding vehicles and can even be
summoned to you while you aren't in the
vehicle those capabilities are
impressive and in some cases even
life-saving but it is still a fair reach
from a full self-driving vehicle
requiring regular input from the driver
to ensure they are paying attention and
capable of taking over when needed there
are three primary challenges automakers
like Tesla need to overcome in order to
succeed in replacing the human driver
the first of those is building a safe
system in order to replace human drivers
the self-driving car needs to be safer
than the human driver so how do we
quantify that we can't guarantee
accidents won't occur old Murphy's Law
is always in play we can start by
quantifying how safe human drivers are
in the US the current fatality rate is
about one death per 1 million hours of
driving that includes humans being
stupid and crashing while drunk or
looking at their phone so we can
probably hold our vehicles to a higher
standard but that can be our benchmark
for now our self-driving vehicle needs
to fail less than once every 1 million
hours and currently that is not the case
we do not have enough data to calculate
an accurate statistic here but we do
know that uber is self-driving vehicle
needed a human to intervene around every
19 kilometers meaning it failed every 19
kilometers which makes you burrs
collision with a pedestrian who
unfortunately passed away even more
shocking supporters of self-driving
vehicles were quick to blame the
pedestrian for stepping in front of the
vehicle in low-light conditions but we
cannot let our desire to advance the
technology to make excuses for it the
vehicle was using lidar sensors which do
not need light to see yes it made no
attempt to slow down even after
the human occupant who was not paying
attention had noticed the imminent crash
according to data obtained from uber the
vehicle first observed the pedestrian
six seconds before impact with its radar
and lidar sensors at this point it was
traveling at 70 km/h it continued at the
speed as the pedestrian and vehicles
paths converged the computers
classifying system is seen struggling to
identify what the object in its view is
jumping from unidentified object to kara
to cyclist with no certainty in the
trajectory path of the object 1.3
seconds before the crash the vehicle
recognized it needed to perform an
emergency break but didn't as it was
programmed not to brake if it would
result in a deceleration over 6.5 m/s
squared instead the human operator is
expected to intervene but the vehicle
was not designed to alert the driver a
shocking design considering our earlier
statistic the driver did intervene a
second before impact by engaging the
steering wheel and braking bringing the
vehicle speeds to 62 km/h too little and
too late to save this person nothing on
the vehicle malfunctioned everything
worked as programmed
it was simply poor programming here the
internal computer was clearly not
programmed to deal with uncertainty
where a human would likely slow down
when confronted with something on the
road that it could not clearly identify
this program simply continued on until
it could identify the threat at which
point it was too late it struggled to
identify the object and predict its path
even with high-resolution lighter so how
can we improve safety a large part of
that lies in the hardware itself and the
programming that goes into it
Tesla unveiled its new purpose-built
computer a chip specifically optimized
for running a neural network which Elon
stated was the first of its kind it has
been designed to be retrofitted into
existing vehicles when customers
purchased the full self-driving upgrade
so is a similar size and draws the same
power as the existing self-driving
computers at 100 watts this has
increased Tesla's self-driving computers
capabilities by 2
thousand one hundred percent allowing it
to process 2300 frames per second two
thousand one hundred and ninety frames
more than their previous iteration a
massive performance jump and that
processing power will be needed to
analyze footage from the suite of
sensors each Tesla has on the right side
of the board are all the connectors for
the different sensors and cameras in the
car that currently consists of three
forward facing cameras all mounted
behind the windshield one is a 120
degree wide angle fisheye lens which
gives situational awareness capturing
traffic lights and objects moving into
the path of travel the second camera is
a narrow angle lens which provides
longer range information needed for
high-speed driving like on a motorway
the third is the main camera which sits
in the middle between these two
applications there are four additional
cameras on the sides of the vehicle
which check for vehicles unexpectedly
entering your lane and provide the
information needed to safely enter
intersections and change lane the eighth
and final camera is located to the rear
which doubles as a parking camera but
has also saved more than a few Tesla's
from being rear-ended the vehicle does
not completely rely on visual cameras it
also makes use of 12 ultrasonic sensors
which provide a 360-degree picture of
the immediate area around the vehicle
and one Ford facing Raider finding the
correct sensor fusion has been a subject
of debate among competing self driving
companies musk recently stated that
anyone relying on lighter sensors which
works similarly to radar but utilize
light instead of radio waves is doomed
and that it's a fool's errand to see why
he said this let's plot the strengths of
each sensor on a radar chart like this
where we rank each feature on a scale of
0 to 5 5 being the best and 0 being
non-existent lidar would look something
like this
it's got great resolution meaning it
provides high detailed information on
what it's detecting works in low and
high light situations is capable of
measuring speed has good range and works
moderately well in poor weather
conditions
biggest weakness however is why mosques
label it the sensors are expensive and
bulky and this is where the second
challenge of building a self-driving car
comes into place building an affordable
system that the average person will be
willing to buy lidar sensors are those
big sensors you see on way mo uber and
most competing self-driving tech mosque
is more than aware of lighters potential
after all
SpaceX utilizes it in their dragon eye
navigation sensor its weaknesses are
simply too much of a sticking point for
Tesla for now who are focused on
building not just a cost-effective
vehicle but a good-looking vehicle lidar
technology is gradually becoming smaller
and cheaper making the technology more
accessible but far from cheap way mo a
subsidiary of Google's parent company
alphabet sells its lidar sensors to any
company that does not compete with its
plans for a self-driving taxi service
when they started in 2009 the per unit
cost of a lidar sensor was around
$75,000 but they have managed to reduce
that cost to $7,500 in the past ten
years by manufacturing the unit's
themselves from what I can tell way more
vehicles use for lidar sensors on each
side of the vehicle
placing the cost for just these sensors
for a third party at $30,000 not far off
the total cost of a base model model 3
this sort of pricing clearly doesn't
line up with Tesla's mission to
accelerate the world's transition to
sustainable transport this issue has
pushed Tesla towards a cheaper sensor
fusion setup let's look at the strengths
and weaknesses of the three other sensor
types to see how Tesla is making do
without lighter first let's look at
radar radar works wonderfully in all
conditions the sensors are small and
cheap capable of detecting speed and
it's range is good for both short and
long distance detection where they fall
is the low resolution data they provide
but this weakness can easily be
augmented by combining it with cameras
regular video cameras look like this on
our radar chart having excellent range
and resolution provide color and
contrast information for readings
science and are extremely small and
cheap combining radar and cameras allows
each to cover the weaknesses of the
other we are still a little weak in
proximity detection but using two
cameras in stereo can allow the cameras
to work like our eyes to estimate
distance when fine-tuned distant
measurement is needed we can use our
ultrasonic sensors which are these
little circular sensors dotted around
the car this gives us solid performance
all around without relying on large
expensive sensors but Tesla is suffering
from a bit of a redundancy problem with
only one forward-facing radar if that
fails there isn't a second radar sensor
to rely upon this is a cost-effective
solution and according to Tesla their
hardware is already capable of allowing
the vehicle to self Drive now they just
need to continue improving on the
software and Tesla is in a fantastic
position to make it work when training a
neural network data is key wham-o has
millions of kilometers driven to gain
data but Tesla has over a billion this
data also extends past just while
autopilot is engaged it also receives
data in areas where autopilot is not
available like city streets accounting
for all the unpredictability of driving
requires an immense amount of training
for a machine learning algorithm and
this is where Tesla's data gives them an
advantage I won't go through the
intricacies of training and neural
network again as I've covered it in the
past in my machine learning versus
cancer video but the key takeaway you
need is that the more data you have to
train the neural network the better it's
going to be Tesla's machine vision does
a decent job of it but there are plenty
of gaps in their abilities a channel
here on YouTube by the name of green tea
only has managed to hack into his
Tesla's vision to show us what the
software actually sees here we can see
the software places bounding boxes
around objects into tax while
categorizing them as carries trucks
bicycles and pedestrians it labels each
with a relative velocity to the vehicle
and what Lane it occupies it highlights
drivable areas marks the lane dividers
and sets a projected path between them
for now this data allows autopilot to
operate on highways but it frequently
struggles with more complicated scenes
here a pedestrian is not detected here
it struggles to tell if a roller skater
is a bike or a pedestrian and here it
drives onto the wrong side of the road
when there is a gap in lane dividers
Tesla of course is more than aware of
these problems and is gradually
improving on its software through
firmware updates adding functionality
like stop line recognition and this
latest self-driving computer is going to
radically increase the computer's
processing power which will allow Tesla
to continue adding functionality without
jeopardizing refresh rates of
information but even if they managed to
develop the perfect computer vision
programming the vehicle on how to handle
every scenario is another hurdle this is
a vital part of building not only a safe
vehicle but a practical self-driving
vehicle which is our third challenge
programming for safety and practicality
often conflict with each other
take the AI program dr. Tom Murphy
developed to do something relatively
simple to play Tetris this program
worked brilliantly but Tetris always
wins the game is unbeatable and you will
eventually lose when confronted with
this option the program did something to
ensure it wouldn't lose it paused the
game if we program a vehicle purely for
safety its safest option is not to drive
driving is an inherently dangerous
operation and programming for the
multitude of scenarios that can arise
while driving is an insanely difficult
task it's easy to say follow the rules
of the road and you will do fine but the
problem is humans don't follow the rules
of the road perfectly take a simple
4-way stop as an example the rules of
the road make this seem like an easy
task the first person to arrive at the
intersection has the right-of-way and in
the case that two vehicles arrive at the
same time the vehicle to the right has
the right-of-way the problem is no
humans follow these rules when Google
began testing their driverless cars in
2009 this was just one of the issues
they ran into when it arrived at one of
these four-way junctions humans kept
nudging forward trying to make their way
unto the junction before their turn the
Google car was programmed to follow the
letter of the law and just like our
tetris program for
earlier the self-driving vehicle was put
in a no-win scenario and stuck on pause
scenarios like this pop up everywhere
and requires programmers to break the
letter of the law and be a little
aggressive sometimes the computer will
need to make difficult decisions and may
at times need to make a decision that
endangers the life of its occupants or
people outside of the vehicle that is
just a natural byproduct of an
inherently dangerous task but if we
continue improving on the technology we
could start to see Road debts plummet
while making taxi services drastically
cheaper and freeing many people from the
financial burden of purchasing a vehicle
Tesla is in a fantastic position to
gradually update their software as they
master each scenario and they don't need
to create the perfect self-driving car
out of the gate and with this latest
computer they're going to be able to
continue improving their technology this
is the fantastic thing about software it
is easily updatable and brilliant have
improved their software by allowing
courses to be downloaded for offline use
on iOS so you can work on learning new
things even on an underground train or a
plane brilliant also recently released
their fantastic course on Python coding
called programming with Python Python is
one of the most widely used programming
languages and it is an excellent first
language for new programmers it can be
used for everything from video games to
data visualization to machine learning
for self-driving vehicles this course
will show you how to use Python to
create intricate drawings coded messages
and beautiful data plots while teaching
you some essential core programming
concepts this is just one of many
courses on brilliant they also just
released a computer science essentials
course and have many more due to be
released soon on things like electricity
and magnetism if I've inspired you and
you want to educate yourself then go to
brilliant org ford slash real
engineering and sign up for free and the
first 500 people to go to that link will
get 20% off the annual premium
subscription so you can get full access
to all their courses as well as the
entire daily challenges archive as
always thanks for watching and thank you
to all my patreon supporters if
you would like to see more from me the
links to my Instagram Twitter subreddit
and discord server are below
[Music]